[Music]
Jepsen's malort is considered by a lot
of people to be the most horrible liquor
they've ever had
Tamim alert tastes like sweaty socks
metallic pine needles cantaloupe plus
tires like rubber technically it's like
a DJ thief realistically sour and regret
it's pretty rough but then it's a
acquired taste that now that I can't
actually get enough
my name is Tremaine Atkinson I am CEO
and head distiller for ch distillery my
best description of the taste of
Jepsen's milord is ass gas and fire all
at the same time I personally love it
and I think it tastes great but maybe
I'm a little weird when a CEO describes
his product is something that tastes
like ass gas and fire it's safe to
assume that there's a story that needs
to be told and that story as it turns
out is one of legend Mille art was
invented in the 1930s by Carl Jefferson
a Swedish immigrant who smoked so many
cigars that it killed his taste buds so
he had to come up with something with
such a strong flavor that it could cut
through and give him a real experience
so do tell where did he come up with we
can say that it does have wormwood in it
and that is its primary flavor and
everything else after that is top secret
but please it's more about wormwood
wormwood is a plant it's really an herb
it looks a little bit just like a twig
with some small leaves on it it grows
just about everywhere when you take a
bite of it it is the most bitter
substance that you really ever could
could bite into please excuse my naivete
but can someone please explain why why
would anyone drink this stuff Jepsen's
malort is an old-school Chicago
tradition Chicago has some really iconic
things about it like deep-dish pizza and
the bean and Lake Michigan I think why
malort is so embraced is because those
other things are nice but milord is kind
of the badass icon of Chicago it it
allows us to be ourselves I wanted to
get involved with milord ever since I
started making booze here in Chicago
because it is such a staple of the
Chicago drinking scene
staple more like an anti staple how many
shots of this could you possibly sell on
average 365 days a year people are
taking 10,000 shots of malort so think
about that every night 10,000 shots of
Mille art are disappearing into people's
bodies that was a really weird way to
say that weird indeed but point made I
vaguely remember my first shot of milord
same I remember my friend who was from
here said oh you gotta try a shot of
this and I took it and I just said hi
why did you do that to me that was how I
was introduced to it but now I love
milord because I love the way it tastes
I think it is fascinating I love the
balance between the pure bitterness and
the herbal and floral flavors that
little touch of sweetness the heat of
the alcohol all of that adds up to me is
a really really interesting taste
experience and I also love the way it
makes me feel I love the way that you
love milord and I only wish that one day
I will be so lucky to love something as
much as you love your beloved milord
[Music]
you